well continuing to monitor the rally
going on in Greenville North Carolina
for news and go back to it live if he
makes any if president Trump in the
meantime though where a fire-breathing
great racist
ben Carson would probably know secretary
Carson has served directly under the
president for two years as Secretary of
Housing Urban Development he joins us
tonight with secretary thanks very much
for coming on good as you you watch the
almost unanimous verdict of the media
that the president is a hard-boiled
racist this is in over the past four
days there's really almost been no other
coverage of anything else what's your
response to that well I've never seen
any evidence for that whatsoever our
conversations have frequently centered
around disadvantaged people in our
country and what we can do to elevate
them and it seems to me like a racist
wouldn't spend so much time on second
chance
legislation he wouldn't spend so much
time with Opportunity Zones trying to
take people who have made a lot of money
and put those unrealized capital gains
into areas that have traditionally been
neglected so that people can rise he
wouldn't spend so much time working on
affordable housing recognizing what that
crisis was then this goes on and on
these are not things that people who are
racist would do so you know people need
to actually look at what the results are
and not spend all of their time parsing
every word and trying to make it fit
their narrative would you work for a
racist no I wouldn't I would be out of
there in two seconds and I've certainly
had an opportunity to see what racism is
you know growing up in Detroit and the
60s why do you think people say that
about the president well you know in a
way you know it's kind of nice that
people are creating such a nice binary
choice you know people will have an
opportunity to decide do they really
like the United States this is on a
magnificent country you know where
someone like me could grow up in poverty
become a brain surgeon and a cabinet
member
you know why would anybody knock a place
like that if it was such a bad place
people wouldn't be forming caravans to
come here and then you can have the
other choice
so people people will have a very very
clear choice so you know let them
continue the fight and define themselves
and let the American people decide but
what I discovered when I was running for
president as I traveled all over the
country and to the small little Hamlet's
in every state is that most of the
people in this country actually have
common sense and you know they're not
going to throw away what we want for
Venezuela when they're decent kind of
people I mean it travel a country is you
have it of course that's the first thing
you discover do you think you can win a
presidential race if you hate the
country it would be it would become very
apparent with your rhetoric that you
were not someone who was a supporter of
our nation and you know the interesting
thing is we have an amazing country
people are trying to come here from all
over the world there's no other place
like it there's no place that has a
history like our country have we made
mistakes absolutely do we learn from
them absolutely is that a reason to
throw out the baby with the bathwater
absolutely not and you know people who
can only focus on a negative aspects of
our country and not see the positive
aspects you have to wonder about what
their motives are you certainly do
secretary ben Carson thanks very much
good to see why it's a pleasure thank
you Tucker